.
Kompanie 2, ruh'n!
(Mann) Kompanie 2, morgen.
- (Alle) Morgen.
Bonjour.
- Bonjour.
Buongiorno.
- Buongiorno.
Bun di.
- Bun di.
Heute ist ein besonderer Tag für uns
an der Genieschule 73.
Besuch Chefin VBS,
Frau Bundesrätin Viola Amherd.
L'Assemblea federale
ha eletto con 148 voti ...
(Frau)
Gewählt ist mit 148 Stimmen ...
... Viola Amherd.
- ... Viola Amherd.
Am 5. Dezember 2018
wählte das Parlament
die Walliserin Viola Amherd
in den Bundesrat.
* Lockere Bassmelodie *
Im Vorfeld der Wahl
wurde die CVP-Nationalrätin
in der Walliser Presse
noch als "linkslastiges
Mauerblümchen" bezeichnet.
Doch jetzt feiern sie im Kanton.
V.a. in Brig, wo sie zwölf Jahre lang
Stadtpräsidentin war.
Viola Amherd,
was ist das für ein Gefühl?- Schön.
Noch nie erlebt, so etwas.
- Nein.
Frauenpower in der Simplon-Stadt.
# Ain't no mountain high enough,
# ain't no valley low enough,
# ain't no river wide enough
# to keep me from getting to you.
# Ain't no mountain high enough.
* Sie ahmen Wolfsheulen nach. *
* Jubel, Pfiffe, Applaus *
Mit Untertiteln
von SWISS TXT
Der grosse Wermutstropfen:
Für die Neue im Bundesrat
bleibt nur das unbeliebte
Verteidigungsdepartement,
das sonst niemand will.
Je te souhaite tout bon
pour ce travail.
Der Moment, in dem Sie wussten:
"Ich bin Verteidigungsministerin."
Wie war die erste Reaktion?
Ich hatte schon erwartet,
dass es so kommen könnte,
wenn ich die Konstellation
in Betracht zog.
Da dachte ich:
"Ja nun, jetzt ist es so."
"Ich mache das."
Ich stelle mir das vor
wie früher als Kind beim Sport:
Der Erste wird gewählt, der Zweite -
und der Letzte bleibt stehen.
Ja, ich ... Vielleicht könnte man
es so sagen. Ich weiss es nicht.
Beim Sport wurde ich
eigentlich nie als Letzte gewählt.
Sportlich ist sie, die neue
Verteidigungs- und Sportministerin.
Hier auf der Bettmeralp im Oberwallis
verbringt sie seit früher Kindheit
ihre Ferien.
Ich selbst bin hier aufgewachsen,
doch unsere Wege haben sich
nur ein einziges Mal gekreuzt -
auf dem Tennisplatz.
1984 war es, glaube ich,
da waren wir zusammen
in einem Team im Plauschdoppel.
Erinnern Sie sich daran?
- Nein.
Ich kann mich erinnern,
dass ich im Plauschdoppel mal
mit Stubu-Wisi, dem Wirt der
Walliserstube, in einem Team war.
Damals waren Sie
die beste Tennisspielerin der Region.
Ja, das weiss ich nicht.
- Eine der besten.
Ich war R3-klassiert.
Ich spielte viele Jahre Interclub.
Es gab bestimmt bessere als mich.
An unser gemeinsames Tennis-Doppel
kann sie sich zwar
nicht mehr erinnern,
doch sie hat sich
dazu bereit erklärt,
dass ich sie zwei Jahre lang
mit der Kamera begleite.
Meine zentrale Frage ist:
Wie wächst man
als Frau ohne militärische Erfahrung
in die Rolle einer
Verteidigungsministerin hinein?
Ich war in jungen Jahren
eher armeekritisch.- Wieso?
Ich kannte es nicht.
Ich sah den Sinn dahinter nicht.
* Ruhige Jazz-Bassmelodie *
Chefin des Departements für Vertei-
digung, Bevölkerungsschutz und Sport.
Zum ersten Mal überhaupt
gibt eine Frau hier den Ton an.
Ihr Bundesratsweibel ist Martin
Siedler, ein Ex-Schweizergardist.
Läuft der Laptop?
- Ja.
Sobald die Technik läuft, muss sie
sich in die neuen Aufgaben einlesen.
Schon jetzt ist klar,
an welchem Geschäft
ihre erste Amtszeit gemessen wird.
Ich muss mich schnell
in eins der grossen Themen
auf dem Tisch einarbeiten:
die Beschaffung von Infrastruktur
zur Sicherung des Luftraums,
also neue Kampfflugzeuge,
Boden-Luft-Verteidigung.
Das ist ein grosses
und wichtiges Dossier.
Und es gibt viele andere.
In der ersten Bundesratssitzung muss
ich bereits ein Geschäft vertreten.
Eins nach dem anderen.
Guten Morgen. Hallo, Toni.
- Guten Start.
Dir auch, danke.
Toni Eder
ist ihr neuer Generalsekretär.
Du hast schon eine Mappe dabei.
Wollen wir uns das anschauen?
Der erste Tag im Büro,
und die Bundesrätin hat
einen persönlichen Bezug zur Armee.
Mich hat die Unwetterkatastrophe
1993 in Brig
natürlich stark geprägt.
Ohne die Unterstützung und Hilfe
der Armee hätte es die Gemeinde,
das kann man wirklich sagen, nicht
aus diesem Sumpf herausgeschafft.
Das Geschiebe,
das ganze Material, das Wasser -
wenn nicht sofort die Armee
mit grossen Maschinen
und Personal gekommen wäre -
und danach
half der Zivilschutz auch -,
hätten wir es nie aus
diesen Problemen herausgeschafft.
In dem Sinne sehe ich da
eine wichtige Funktion der Armee -
neben der Sicherheit, die sie
für unser Land gewährleisten muss.
Ein kalter Januartag 2019.
Die neue VBS-Chefin ist erstmals
auf Besuch bei ihrer Truppe.
Die Armee
ist beim WEF in Davos im Einsatz.
Angeflogen kommt sie,
Symbole sind ja wichtig,
mit einer reinen
Frauen-Helikoptercrew.
Hervorragend, dass jetzt
eine Frau an der Spitze ist.
So können wir dokumentieren,
dass wir für alle da sind.
Vielleicht bringen wir auch
das Frauliche ein wenig rein.
Vielleicht können wir
die eine oder andere Sache
auf eine feminine Art
weiterentwickeln -
sicher sympathisch
und sicher zielführend.
* Lockere Bassmelodie *
Die SRF-Kollegin fragt
die neue Verteidigungsministerin
nach ihrer Vision
für die Schweizer Armee.
Wir Frauen betrachten
Sicherheitsfragen ein wenig anders.
Wir haben eine andere Erlebniswelt.
Was muss eine gute Armee
Ihrer Meinung nach erfüllen?
Ich denke,
was das Sicherheitsbedürfnis
und das Sicherheitsgefühl angeht,
sind Männer und Frauen
nicht verschieden.
Wir alle
wollen in einer sicheren Welt leben.
Es ist Aufgabe der Armee,
die Sicherheit der Bevölkerung
zu gewährleisten.
Die Sicherheit -
der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner.
Bei den Soldaten kommt Viola Amherd
offenbar bereits gut an.
Sind alle drauf?
Sehr gut.
- Ich hatte einen guten Assistenten.
Montag 18. März 2019, früh am Morgen.
Viola Amherd ist mit ihrer Beraterin,
Brigitte Hauser, unterwegs nach Bern.
Ruhe hatte sie
an diesem Wochenende kaum.
Am Sonntag
musste sie sich als Sportministerin
zu einer heiklen Sache äussern,
und zwar wegen dieser
Fussball-Randale in Sitten.
Chaoten der Grasshoppers Zürich
provozierten mit Petarden
einen Spielabbruch.
Vielen Dank.
Wie fühlt sich das an?
Das gehört einfach zum Geschäft.
Solange die Schlagzeilen gut sind,
fühlt es sich natürlich auch gut an.
Aber im Verlauf der Arbeit
wird auch anderes kommen.
Der "Blick" schreibt,
dass Sie den Tarif durchgeben.
Was heisst das konkret
als Sportministerin?
Ich kann den Klubs
natürlich nichts vorschreiben,
aber als Sportministerin
ist für mich wichtig,
dass Sport Sport bleibt und man ihn
nicht zum Randalieren missbraucht
und solche Veranstaltungen ausnutzt,
um Krawall zu machen.
Das darf nicht sein.
Ich habe ein Interesse daran,
dass der Sport gut läuft,
dass er die Funktion des Breiten-
und Spitzensports wahrnehmen kann,
dass er der Gesamtbevölkerung etwas
bringt und keinen Schaden anrichtet.
Dann die Hauptaufgabe des Tages:
Medienkonferenz zusammen mit
Vertretern des Rüstungskonzerns RUAG.
Der bundesnahe Betrieb
ist seit Längerem
nicht mehr nur Armeeausrüster,
sondern ein international tätiger
Technologiekonzern.
2015 hatten Hacker monatelang die
Computersysteme der RUAG angegriffen.
Über 20 GB Daten,
auch aus der Bundesverwaltung,
wurden von den Spionen kopiert.
2016 wurde ein Cyberangriff
auf die RUAG entdeckt.
Damit wurde deutlich,
dass sich die Strukturen
zwischen dem Unternehmen
mit seinen weltweiten Standorten
und dem VBS über die Jahre
zu eng verflochten haben.
Insbesondere die Informatik
war anfällig geworden.
Das war auch ein Sicherheitsrisiko.
Nicht nur,
aber auch wegen dieser Spionage
soll die RUAG teilprivatisiert
und somit auch ihre Informatik
vom Bund getrennt werden.
Davon will sie alle überzeugen.
Der Bund will die RUAG aus Gründen
der Sicherheit aufteilen.
Wir teilen sie
aus verschiedenen Gründen auf.
Erstens: Sicherheit.
Das Ziel ist insbesondere,
eine bessere Sicherheit
gewährleisten zu können.
Aber ist sie denn
überhaupt selbst überzeugt?
Wenn ich eine Funktion habe, will
ich sie richtig und gut erfüllen.
Ich setze mich
mit dem Thema auseinander.
Wenn ich hier
etwas vertreten müsste,
das absolut
gegen mein Gewissen geht,
würde mir das schwerfallen.
Aber das sind Themen,
in die ich mich eingearbeitet habe.
Ich konnte viel Neues lernen,
das ich vorher vielleicht
etwas oberflächlich betrachtet habe.
Etwas lernen
will die neue VBS-Chefin auch
bei den Soldaten der Genieschule 73.
Diese sehen dem Besuch
gelassen entgegen.
Geschossen wird nur auf dem Handy.
Komm zu mir! Mann!
Wo macht's mehr Spass:
am Handy oder im Wald?
Am Handy muss man danach
das Gewehr nicht putzen.
* Geheimnisvolle Bassmusik *
So, guten Tag.
Wir haben Erfrischungen vorbereitet.
Wir dachten, auf dem langen Weg
von Aarau würden Sie ...
... fast verhungern.
- Genau.
Haben Sie es hier immer so schön?
- Ja.
Gut.
... Marty - er wird ...
- Guten Tag, Herr Marty.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Morgen.
Frau Bundesrätin ...
- Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Sie über meinen Zug und
unseren Arbeitsplatz orientieren.
Hier haben wir
Wachtmeister Niederhauser,
der seiner Gruppe gerade
die Benzinbohrmaschine erklärt.
Im Hintergrund erklärt Wachtmeister
Holt den Trennschleifer.
Jetzt würde ich ...
Den Trennschleifer
müssen Sie mir auch erklären.
Der neuen Chefin wird erklärt,
wie die Genietruppen arbeiten -
und das sehr detailliert.
Darüber können 80 t,
in Ausnahmefällen 120 t fahren.
Sogar?
Genau. Mit einer Geschwindigkeit
von 25 km/h.
Jawohl. Super.
Das ist eine sog. schnelle Brücke,
d.h., wir bauen sie in 3 Std. auf.
Für die gesamten 46 m
brauchen wir 4 Std.
Das Fahrzeug ist normal zugelassen,
damit wir auf jeder Schweizer
Strasse fahren können.
Gut.
- Haben Sie Fragen zu dieser Brücke?
Im Moment nicht, danke.
Guten Tag.
- Adj Gerber.
Viola Amherd sagt über sich selbst,
sie habe einen guten Sinn für Humor.
Das ist jetzt nicht die Marine.
Fast.
- Fast? Gut.
Tatsächlich dringt dieser
immer wieder mal durch.
Zum Glück habe ich das Segelbrevet -
ich weiss, wie ich mich
auf dem Wasser zu benehmen habe.
Ich würde meine Bluse opfern,
wenn wir ein Segel setzen müssten.
Aber es werden auch ernsthafte Themen
an sie herangetragen.
Z.B. die Zukunft
des Waffenplatzes Brugg.
Wie lange dieser weiter bestehen
soll, ist Diskussionsthema im VBS.
Die Mutigsten der Truppe trauen sich
dann, eine Frage zu stellen.
Er hat eine Frage.
- Frau Bundesrätin, Rekrut Schenk.
Sind Sie
mit Ihrem Departement zufrieden?
Man konnte über die Departements-
verteilung allerhand lesen.
Vielleicht
haben Sie das mitbekommen.
Ehrlich gesagt,
hätte ich auswählen können,
hätte ich wahrscheinlich
das Justizdepartement genommen -
ich bin ja Juristin.
Aber jetzt, da ich es gesehen habe,
muss ich sagen,
dass ich grosses Glück hatte.
Ich habe jetzt die Chance,
viele neue Dinge kennenzulernen.
Im Justizdepartement wäre ich
in ausgetretene Pfade geraten.
Das hier ist für mich neu.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden mit dem,
was ich bisher gesehen habe.
Danke.
Was halten Sie
von einer Dienstpflicht für Frauen?
Für mich ist klar, dass mehr Frauen
in der Armee sein sollten.
Ich weiss nicht, ob Sie das wissen,
aber momentan sind es ja 0,7 %.
Das ist nicht viel.
Diesen Anteil
sollte man unbedingt erhöhen,
weil gemischte Teams
in der Wirtschaft und überall
bessere Resultate bringen.
Dazu gibt's auch Studien.
Darum ist es mir ein Anliegen,
den Frauenanteil zu erhöhen.
Ob man dafür ein Obligatorium
für Frauen einführen muss,
weiss ich noch nicht so sicher.
Ich setze mich immer schon
stark für Gleichstellung ein.
Aber ich sage immer:
einen Schritt nach dem anderen.
Vielen Dank.
Schritt für Schritt,
das scheint also Viola Amherds
Motto in ihrem neuen Amt zu sein -
so, wie man es wohl
von einer Mittepolitikerin erwartet.
Gut.
- Dann führen wir Sie in die Maske.
Sendung "Rundschau talk".
Die VBS-Chefin hinter den Kulissen.
Sind Sie schon
für die Sendung angezogen?- Ja.
Wie hätten Sie's gerne?
Natürlichkeit und hinten betont?
Genau.
- Gut.
Einfach etwas frisch
in dieser Hitze.
Genau.
Die schönen Augen
brauchen wir nicht weiter betonen.
Nicht? Gut.
Schauen Sie das dann um 20 Uhr?
Ich sehe mir meine Sendungen nie an.
- Wirklich?
Ja.
Wieso nicht?
- Ich bin sehr selbstkritisch.
Da schaue ich es lieber nicht,
sondern warte lieber
auf Feedback von anderen.
Die sagen mir schon,
was gut war und was nicht.
Darauf verlasse ich mich.
Also konsequent?
- Ja.
Auch in "Rundschau talk" zeigt sich,
dass Amherd nicht die Frau
der grossen Umbrüche ist.
D.h., Sie müssen den Laden
ziemlich auf den Kopf stellen
und die DNA von Grund auf verändern.
Ich muss nicht alles
auf den Kopf stellen.
Ich kannte die Armee ja auch nicht,
und ich muss ehrlich sagen,
dass ich positiv überrascht bin,
wie gut es läuft.
Meistens hört man ja
nur die negativen Sachen.
Ich habe sehr gute Leute erlebt, die
super arbeiten, die engagiert sind,
die auch Freude an der Arbeit haben.
Es gibt viel Gutes.
Wollen wir sie fliegen lassen?
(Mann) Wartet,
ich will das auf Video haben.
Achtung, fertig, Start.
So ein Quatsch.
Vom Spass zum Ernst.
Die Bundesrätin weiss, dass
die Bilanz ihrer ersten Amtsjahre
mit den Kampfjets steht und fällt.
Die Nutzungsdauer
der derzeitigen F/A-18
neige sich langsam dem Ende zu,
sagt die Militärführung.
Man benötige neue Kampfjets.
Aber darüber wird wie früher
das Volk abstimmen.
2014 war der damalige
VBS-Chef Ueli Maurer
mit seinen Gripen-Flugzeugen
gescheitert.
Die Menschen im Land
sind also kritisch.
Doch Amherd
macht einen klugen Schachzug.
Sie beauftragt den ehemaligen
Astronauten Claude Nicollier.
Er soll den Bericht der Armee
neutral beurteilen.
Nicollier ist beliebt
und gilt als kompetent,
weil er früher selbst Kampfjets flog.
Tatsächlich bekommt die Schweiz
von Nicollier dann das zu hören,
was sich die Verteidigungsministerin
erhofft hat.
Wenn wir konkret
den Kampfjet nehmen ...
Ich kenne Sie von früher als eine,
die sich
für Kinder und Jugendliche
und gegen Gewalt gegen
Jugendliche und Kinder einsetzt.
Da spürte man auch Herzblut.
Wo nimmt man da plötzlich
das Herzblut für Kampfjets her?
Ich denke,
das ist gar kein Widerspruch.
Ich habe mich stark für den Kinder-
und Jugendschutz eingesetzt,
damit Kinder in einer
sicheren, vertrauensvollen Umgebung
aufwachsen können, in der sie sich
gut entwickeln können.
Damit sie auch Vertrauen
in jene haben dürfen,
die für sie
die Verantwortung tragen.
Wenn ich hier im Departement
verschiedene Systeme
beschaffen muss -
z.B. Kampfflugzeuge
oder Boden-Luft-Verteidigung -,
sind das alles Systeme
zum Schutz der Bevölkerung.
Die Sicherheit der Bevölkerung
ist für mich sehr wichtig,
denn sie ist die Basis für die
Entwicklung des gesamten Landes -
wirtschaftlich,
gesellschaftlich usw.
Darum denke ich, dass das
ein sehr wichtiges Thema ist,
das eigentlich meinen Einsatz
für Kinder und Jugendliche
jetzt für
die Gesamtbevölkerung weiterführt.
Eine der ersten Auslandreisen führt
die Bundesrätin an ein Weltereignis.
In Japan wird mit dem 59-jährigen
Naruhito der neue Kaiser gekrönt.
Banzai!
- (Männer) Banzai!
- Banzai!
Die internationale Elite
versammelt sich.
Rund 2'000 Gäste und VIPs
aus 190 Ländern sind vor Ort.
Royals, Präsidenten,
Regierungsmitglieder.
Und mittendrin:
die bodenständige Walliserin.
Auch sie bekommt Gelegenheit
zum Austausch auf höchster Ebene.
* Kein Ton *
Was haben Sie
bei der Gratulation gesagt?
Ich habe mir sagen lassen,
dass alle Mikrofone ausgeschaltet
werden, wenn der Kaiser spricht.
Ich gratulierte,
wie man das so macht.
Und ich sagte, ich hätte gehört,
er kenne die Schweiz
und das freue mich.
Er erzählte,
er habe hier schon gewandert,
und sie sagte, ihre Schwester
sei in Genf zur Schule gegangen.
Sie waren auch schon in der Schweiz.
Es sei ein sehr schönes Land.
Ich sagte,
es würde mich sehr freuen,
wenn sie die Schweiz
mal wieder besuchen würden.
Kaiserlicher Smalltalk in Japan,
Alltagsgeschäft in Bern -
heute als Sportministerin.
Jetzt fahren wir fast 2 Std.,
damit ich 5 Min. rede.
Stimmt's, Renato?
- Ja, das stimmt schon.
Geplant ist ein Auftritt
am Swiss Olympic Forum in Interlaken.
Doch der neue Kampfjet
steht dennoch im Zentrum.
In wenigen Tagen will sie
ihre Botschaft mit Vorschlägen
insbesondere über den Kostenrahmen
an den Bundesrat übergeben.
Doch Details
darüber sind durchgesickert
und in der Sonntagspresse erschienen.
Es gab in der Presse bereits erste
Informationen über die Botschaft,
die Sie
dem Bundesrat schicken wollen.
Haben Sie sie selbst rausgelassen?
Ist das Taktik?
Ich bin sehr für Transparenz,
aber ich informiere meine
Bundesratskolleginnen und -kollegen
schon lieber vor der Öffentlichkeit.
Es ist sicher klar, dass solche
Informationen nicht von mir kommen.
Ich halte den korrekten Weg ein.
Als Bundesratsmitglied
bin ich auch nicht glücklich,
wenn ich etwas aus einem anderen
Departement in der Zeitung lese,
bevor es im Bundesrat
diskutiert worden ist.
Aber wie kann so etwas passieren?
Was ist schiefgelaufen?
Offenbar ist es heute so,
dass man mit Leaks rechnen muss.
Das gibt es praktisch überall.
Ich habe das
schon als Parlamentarierin
in den Kommissionen erlebt. Dort
kennt man das Kommissionsgeheimnis.
Trotzdem gab es in
praktisch jeder Kommission Leaks.
Das ist ein Spiel,
das mir überhaupt nicht gefällt.
Aus Lausanne.
- Es ist sehr schön.
Sport ist viel mehr
als Erfolg an Wettkämpfen.
Sport ist im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes eine Lebensschule.
Man macht Erfahrungen, die im Leben
von zentraler Bedeutung sind.
Ich möchte ergänzen,
dass sie auch in der Politik
von zentraler Bedeutung sind.
Lassen Sie mich das
am Beispiel Tennis erläutern.
In dieser Sportart habe ich meine
sportlichen Erfahrungen gesammelt.
Tennis zu spielen heisst,
einander den Ball zuzuspielen,
aber auch zu punkten,
wenn die Gelegenheit günstig ist,
stets in Bewegung zu bleiben,
zu antizipieren
und sein Gegenüber
richtig einzuschätzen,
um den Verlauf des Spiels erkennen
und auch bestimmen zu können.
So, ist das auch vorbei.
Und schon geht's
um die nächsten Terminanfragen.
Auf der Dienstfahrt
erhasche ich einen Einblick,
wie Amherd sich den Ruf
einer Strippenzieherin erworben hat.
Es geht um ihre neue Wohnung in Bern.
Auch in ihrer neuen Wohnung
will sie allein leben.
Wenn man Sie
nach Ihrem Privatleben fragt,
sagen Sie oft:
"Ich bin eine überzeugte Single."
Das habe ich eigentlich
nie so gesagt.
Der Journalist schrieb das so,
und viele schrieben es ab.
Ist das so?
- Ja.
Das Wort "überzeugt"
habe ich sicher nie gesagt.
Ich sagte, ich fühle mich mit meinem
Leben wohl und bin sehr zufrieden.
Mir geht's gut.
Daraus wurde dann "überzeugte" ...
Was schrieb er?
"Überzeugte Single".
- Ja.
Aber wahrscheinlich ...
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass es mir gut geht.
Mir gefällt mein Leben.
Ich bin einfach zufrieden.
Mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Sie haben gesagt,
sie erhalten viele Briefe.
Auch von Verehren oder Verehrerinnen?
Einen Heiratsantrag
habe ich noch nicht bekommen.
Aber wären Sie offen?
- Also ...
Je älter man wird,
desto mehr nehmen die Eigenarten zu.
Darum strebe ich das nicht an.
Das war's dann auch zum Thema
Privat- und Beziehungsleben.
Im Stockalperschloss in Brig
war Viola Amherd jahrelang
als Stadtpräsidentin tätig.
Radiochefredaktor Michel Venetz
bereitet das Interview
zum 1. August vor.
Er kennt Amherd schon lange
und nennt einen wohl zentralen Punkt
für ihren erfolgreichen Start im VBS.
Sie hat in Brigitte Hauser
eine gute Kommunikationsberaterin,
aber ich glaube, auch VBS-Chef
Renato Kalbermatten weiss,
wie er im Umgang mit den Medien
vorgehen muss.
Man sieht auch, dass sie viel
in den Medien präsent ist
und die Themen setzen kann,
wie sie will.
Ich hätte ihr
eigentlich nicht zugetraut,
dass es so senkrecht
nach oben gehen würde.
Bescheiden und doch medienwirksam
erscheint die neue Landesmutter
zum Interviewtermin.
Können Sie das Kabel
unter zwei, drei Knöpfe stecken?
Da drehe ich mich um.
- Vielleicht nicht gleich filmen.
Frau Bundesrätin, Sie waren ja auch
bei anderen Verteidigungsministern,
z.B. in Wien.
Ist es eine Schweizer Eigenart,
dass man hier
eine Regierung zum Anfassen hat?
Das ist aussergewöhnlich, nicht?
Ja, ich denke, das ist einmalig.
In unserem Land
ist die Sicherheit so gross,
dass wir uns das erlauben können.
Frau von der Leyen
kam mit sechs Leibwächtern
aus Deutschland nach Wien.
Dann hat uns dort auch die örtliche
Sicherheitspolizei begleitet.
Ich ging sozusagen allein hin,
also mit meiner
persönlichen Mitarbeiterin
und dem militärischen Berater.
Wir hatten keine eigenen
Sicherheitsleute dabei.
Das sind ganz andere Dimensionen.
Da haben wir ein Riesenglück.
In Münster im Obergoms geht Amherd
auf Tuchfühlung mit dem Volk.
Die erste 1.-August-Rede
ihrer Karriere ist ein Heimspiel.
* Jubel *
Hallo. Salut.
Salut. Hallo. Guten Abend.
Wie geht's dir?
- Gut.
Schön, dass du mal ins Goms kommst.
- Ja, hey.
Geht's gut?
- Ja, und dir?
Darf ich ein Foto machen?
- Sicher.
(Mann) Viola, ein Selfie mit mir?
- Ein Selfie, jawohl.
Ich komme aus Genf.
Wunderbar, danke.
- Bitte, gerne.
Ich wollte mich
für Ihre klaren Worte bedanken.
Danke.
Ich habe eine Angestellte,
die mit Ihnen
im selben Block aufgewachsen ist.
Je veux l'envoyer à notre ministre à
Paris. Aussi la ministre de l'armée.
Mme Parly? Oui,
j'ai déjà faire la connaissance.
Du machst das super.
- Merci.
Wir sind nicht
in derselben Partei,
aber ich bin zufrieden mit dir.
Ganz wichtig.
Ich finde es super,
dass Sie hier sind.
Ich wollte mal Hallo sagen.
Kennst du mich noch?
Ja, doch.
- Olga sitzt dort.
Wo?
Salut, Herbert. Wie geht's?
- Alles Gute.
Man hört nur Gutes.
- Gut.
Abt Martin würde gerne mal
mit dir Cholleri essen.
Da ist die Chefin der Termine.
Mich überrascht, wie sehr
Amherd das Bad in der Menge geniesst.
Aber auch hier nutzt sie die Chance,
um Werbung für den Jet zu machen.
Ich bin stolz,
das Departement für Verteidigung,
Bevölkerungsschutz und Sport
als Vorsteherin führen zu dürfen.
Ein zwölfjähriges Mädchen
aus Srebrenica
wurde vor einigen Jahren gefragt:
"Was ist Heimat?"
Und es antwortete: "Heimat ist da,
wo ich keine Angst haben muss."
In der heutigen Zeit
sind kriegerische Auseinander-
setzungen zwischen Staaten,
aber auch Terroranschläge gegen
die Gesellschaft an der Tagesordnung
und in weiten der Welt Realität.
Tatsache ist,
dass praktisch alle Mittel
zum Schutz der Schweiz vor Gefahren
aus der Luft erneuert werden müssen.
Die Stimmbürger/-innen werden
voraussichtlich im Herbst 2020
über die Beschaffung neuer
Kampfflugzeuge abstimmen können.
Sie alle,
die Sie hier anwesend sind,
können über Ihre Sicherheit
und Ihren Schutz entscheiden.
* Fröhliche Ländlermusik *
So habe ich die Chefin
auch noch nie gesehen. Super.
Wussten Sie, dass sie das kann?
Ich wusste nicht,
dass sie so gut tanzen kann.
Aber es ist wirklich super.
Sie könnten ja mal ...
Sie hat vorhin schon gefragt,
aber ich bin kein so guter Tänzer.
Walliser Aprikosen,
das ist meine Lieblingskonfitüre.
Ach ja?
Und dann Himbeere, Heidelbeere ...
Ich mag Orangen oder Kirsche.
- Die mag ich beide am wenigsten.
Ach! Gut,
du darfst die Aprikose haben.
Nein, schon gut. Ich habe noch
vom letzten Jahr und dem davor.
Ich brauche so wenig.
Sonst schimmelt sie nur.
Was mir beim Recherchieren über Sie
aufgefallen ist:
Man weiss viel darüber,
was Sie politisch getan haben,
aber wenn man fragt,
wer Viola Amherd eigentlich ist,
sagen viele,
sie würden Sie nicht näher kennen.
Vielleicht, weil ich
nicht ständig unter Leuten bin.
Ich ging zwar oft an Feste und so,
aber ich war immer
eher zurückhaltend.
Und so werde ich auch bleiben.
- Ja.
Sie haben also nie
über die Stränge geschlagen?
Tja ...
Dazu sage ich besser nichts.
Es gab sicher auch Zeiten,
in denen ich aktiver war.
Ich ging während des Studiums
auch mit Freunden aus.
Das gehört selbstverständlich
auch dazu.
Viel mehr als ihre Lieblingskonfitüre
ist auch hier nicht drin
beim Thema Privatleben.
Immerhin: Auf eine echte
Trouvaille aus ihrer Kindheit
stiess ich im Fernseharchiv.
Das "Dreiländerspiel",
aufgenommen 1976 in München.
Unser Team aus der Schweiz!
Viola,
was kannst du uns über Brig sagen?
Was sehen wir auf diesem Bild?
Wir sehen das Stockalperschloss.
Es wurde im 17. Jh. erbaut.
Von wem?
- Von Jodok von Stockalper.
Er hatte das Salzmonopol
in der Schweiz.
Wir haben zwei Kübel voll Wasser,
und hier haben wir zwei Behälter.
Einer fasst 3 l Wasser,
der andere 5 l Wasser.
Eure Aufgabe ist,
durch Umleeren einen 1 l abzumessen.
Ganz genau 1 l.
1 l abmessen.
* Fröhliche Blasmusik *
Einfach mal anfangen.
Das gibt 30 Punkte für die
Schweizer, die waren zuerst fertig.
Was wollt ihr mit dem Geld machen?
Habt ihr
eine Reisekasse in der Schule?
Da die Klasse uns gewählt hat,
hier mitzumachen,
lassen wir die das entscheiden.
- Gut.
Gut, ihr nehmt das Geld mit
und sagt:
"Hier, 300 Fränkli."
So viel ist das ungefähr.
Der Umrechnungskurs ist gleich.
Bundesratsferien auf der Bettmeralp.
Doch eine Armeechefin
ist auch in der Gondel
nicht sicher vor Kritikern und Fans.
Hallo zusammen.
- Hallo.
Ach, Sie sind ja Frau Amherd.
- Genau.
Grüezi, Frau Bundesrätin.
Endlich mal eine Frau,
die das Militärdepartement führt.
Diejenigen,
die gegen die Armee sind -
ich will nicht politisieren,
Sie haben den ganzen Tag
Politik um die Ohren -,
sehen nicht von A nach Z.
Wer hat damals in Randa aufgeräumt,
die Unwetterkatastrophe im Goms?
Überschwemmungen,
z.B. in Brig, Randa ...
Braucht man Flugzeuge,
um Brig aufzuräumen?- Flugzeuge?
Gute Frage.
Wir brauchen die Luftwaffe.
Vielleicht nicht,
um Brig aufzuräumen.
Aber wir brauchen
einen gesicherten Luftraum.
Diejenigen,
die gegen die Flieger sind,
sollen in 20 Jahren nicht jammern,
weil wir keine Sicherheit haben.
Aber das
wissen Sie ja besser als ich.
Nein, da soll man ehrlich sein
und die Abschaffung verlangen.
Aber solange wir sie haben,
braucht sie auch die Mittel,
um arbeiten zu können.
- Stimmt.
Sonst hat man etwas Halbes,
das nichts tun kann,
wenn's drauf ankommt.
Darf ich fragen:
Waren Sie damals gegen die Armee?
Ich habe damals
für die Abschaffung gestimmt, ja.
Und jetzt?
- Ja, jetzt ...
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich bin nicht so sicher.
Ich bin etwas weit
von der Armee weg.
Ich weiss nicht, was sie heute
als Bedrohungslage sieht.
Man hat sie schon stark angepasst.
Im letzten sicherheitspolitischen
Bericht steht klar,
dass man nicht von traditionellen
Konflikten wie damals ausgehen kann.
Es gibt total
unterschiedliche Formen -
sog. hybride Konfliktsituationen.
Das können z.B. Cyberangriffe sein -
oder irgendwelche anderen.
Dem passt man sich schon an.
Konkret habe man, so Amherd,
die Spionageabwehr ausgebaut
mit 100 neuen Stellen
im Nachrichtendienst.
Auch für die Cyberabwehr
will sie mehr Personal
und eine intensivere Zusammenarbeit
mit dem Ausland.
Die internationale Sicherheitslage
verschlechtere sich.
Die Hauptgefahren für die Schweiz
seien Cyberangriffe und Terrorismus.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass die Schweiz in der Lage ist,
ihre Grenzen zu schützen.
Das ist unmöglich.
Da bin ich anderer Meinung.
Wir haben einen grossen
Geländevorteil: die Alpen.
Das darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Wir kennen unser Gebiet,
und wir werden unterschätzt.
Wir haben
eine sehr gut ausgebildete Armee.
Da muss ich Frau Amherd
und Herrn Maurer in Schutz nehmen.
Wir haben eine starke,
gut ausgebildete Armee.
Es ist auch wichtig,
dass wir auch innerhalb von Europa
unsere Aufgaben wahrnehmen
und etwas für die Sicherheit tun.
Würden wir uns
nur auf die anderen verlassen,
würden wir
die Solidarität ausnutzen.
Uns geht's wirtschaftlich gut.
Dass ausgerechnet wir nichts tun,
das geht nicht.
Das war eine flotte Fahrt.
Machen wir noch ein Foto?
Gut.
- Danke.
Schönen Tag.
Der Ernstfall
tritt schon einen Monat später ein.
März 2020:
Die Armee macht mobil
gegen das Coronavirus.
Eine Mobilmachung der Armee
in diesem Ausmass
gab es seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mehr.
Achtung!
Stabskompanie, ruh'n!
Helm ab!
Als Ihr Kommandant
bin ich stolz auf Sie.
Jeder von Ihnen
hat vielleicht Angst.
"Was passiert mit mir?"
"Wie geht es weiter? Wie lange?"
Aber seien wir mutig
und leisten wir das,
was von uns verlangt wird.
Mme Amherd.
- Ja.
Besuch bei Spital-
und Sanitätssoldaten
im medizinischen Einsatz.
S'il vous plait, donnez un masque.
- Merci beaucoup. Je dois la mettre?
Seulement tirer.
- Tirer.
Oui. Voilà.
- Okay, merci.
In diesem Zelt
wird an Soldaten geübt -
für den Fall,
dass die tatsächliche Patientenzahl
die Kapazität des Kantonsspitals
übersteigen sollte.
Das hier ist ein Beatmungsgerät.
Mit dem hier
simulieren wir eine Lunge.
* Heller Pfeifton *
Das zeigt, wie eine
künstliche Atmung funktioniert.
Venez, venez, venez.
Deux mètres entre vous.
Die Soldaten dort bei der Triage,
bringen sie Patienten hierher,
die nicht ins Spital können?
Momentan ist es im Spital ruhig.
Wir brauchen die Zelte hier nicht.
Wenn es zu einer Krise
mit einem starken Anstieg
von Patientenzahlen käme,
würde man sie hierherbringen.
Vielen Dank Ihnen allen,
den Frauen und den Männern hier,
für Ihre Arbeit.
(Alle) Merci.
Rund 5'000 Soldaten
wurden aufgeboten.
Sie halfen in Spitälern
oder bei Krankentransporten,
aber bei Weitem nicht alle.
Viele wurden über Wochen
in Reserve gehalten,
ohne je wirklich helfen zu können.
Zudem gab es Fälle,
in denen Spitäler Pflegepersonal
in Kurzarbeit schickten
und durch Soldaten ersetzten.
Es lief einiges schief.
Auch während
der zweiten Corona-Welle im Herbst
bekamen Soldaten ein Aufgebot, aber
diesmal nur mehr ein paar Hundert.
Jetzt im Herbst ist es von der Zahl
der Toten oder der Ansteckungen her
schlimmer als im Frühling, aber
es sind weniger Soldaten im Einsatz.
Anerkennt man damit, dass im Frühling
zu viel mobilisiert wurde?
Die Armee hat sich ja nicht
selbst mobilisiert oder bestimmt,
wie viele wohin gehen sollen.
Dafür kamen immer
Gesuche von den Kantonen.
Im Nachhinein hat man gesehen,
dass die Kantone vielleicht ...
... eher zu viel verlangt haben.
Aber ich mache ihnen keinen Vorwurf.
Sie wussten auch nicht genau,
wie das funktioniert.
Man sah die Bilder aus Italien,
auf denen die Armee
mit Lkws Leichen abtransportierte.
Das waren furchtbare Bilder.
Darum gingen alle auf Nummer sicher.
Wir sagten, bei einem erneuten Ein-
satz müssten wir es besser machen.
Dieses Mal
wurden nicht alle Gesuche bewilligt,
zumindest nicht in vollem Umfang.
Es ist September.
Heisse Phase für Viola Amherd und
die Abstimmung über neue Kampfjets.
Die Umfragen
prognostizieren ein solides Ja.
Ich gebe Ihnen das Zeichen,
dass Sie hinten herumgehen können.
Wollen Sie ... Ist das für Sie okay?
- Ja.
Hinten rum, und dann
ist das der Weg zu Ihrem Podium.
Die Zürcher SP-Nationalrätin
Priska Seiler Graf
ist eine wichtige Vertreterin
des Nein-Lagers.
Die Umfragen deuten an, dass es
nicht nach Ihren Wünschen ausgeht.
Was denken Sie, woran das liegt?
Was der Bundesrat sagt,
geniesst in der Bevölkerung
meist eine hohe Glaubwürdigkeit.
In diesem speziellen Fall
liegt es wohl auch
an Bundesrätin Viola Amherd.
Inwiefern?
- Sie ist beim Volk sehr beliebt.
Sie wirkt sehr authentisch,
geerdet und sachlich.
Das macht es uns
leider etwas schwieriger.
Mir wäre Ueli Maurer lieber als sie,
denn da könnte ich voll loslegen.
Bei ihr habe ich Beisshemmungen,
weil ich finde,
dass sie das super macht.
Was nützen uns Kampfflugzeuge
und ein geschützter Luftraum,
wenn wir keinen Planeten mehr
zu beschützen haben,
weil wir ihn nämlich zerstört haben?
Das ist die wichtigere
und wesentliche Frage.
Man kann nicht das eine
gegen das andere ausspielen.
Sie können fragen, was uns die Jets
nützen, wenn der Planet kaputt ist,
wir Befürworter können fragen,
was uns ein grüner Planet nützt,
wenn wir angegriffen
und getötet werden.
Gott sei Dank
leben wir in einem friedlichen Land,
aber sehen Sie sich andere
Länder an, in denen Krieg herrscht.
Dort hat man keine Zeit,
um übers Klima zu diskutieren.
Ade.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
Im Moment nicht,
aber es bessert gleich.
Gut.
- Ein schönes Wochenende.
Gleichfalls, und gute Erholung.
- Dir auch.
Tschau, Viola.
Neben Kampfjet und Corona
beschäftigt Viola Amherd schon
während ihrer gesamten Amtszeit
eine weitere Herausforderung
mit Explosionsgefahr:
das Munitionslager Mitholz
im Kandertal.
(Originalton)
Die Felswand über dem Lager
ist auf 100 m Länge eingestürzt.
Alle Häuser von Mitholz
sind zerstört oder beschädigt.
Im Dezember 1947 explodierten hier
über 800 t gelagerter Munition.
Neun Menschen kamen dabei ums Leben,
darunter auch Kinder.
Hunderte Meter im Berginnern
finden wir im Schutt
noch immer Munition aller Art.
Ortstermin an der Unglücksstelle
zusammen mit lokalen Politikerinnen
und Spezialisten.
Merken Sie sich den Weg,
den wir nehmen,
denn das ist auch der Fluchtweg.
Bei einem Alarm müssten wir
denselben Weg zurück nehmen,
damit wir gesund rauskommen,
wie es sich gehört.
Ich bin darauf gespannt.
Das Dossier kenne ich, aber ...
Jahrzehntelang galt das Risiko
von weiteren Explosionen als tragbar,
bis neue Studien aufzeigten:
Die restlichen rund
3'500 t gelagerter Munition
sind meist noch aktiv
und könnten explodieren.
Zusätzlich
zur Sicherheitsunterweisung
müssen alle
einen Notfallkontakt angeben.
Tiefer im Stollen
ist Filmen streng verboten.
Die Kameras könnten, genau
wie Handys, einen Alarm provozieren.
Dies könnte die Evakuierung
der ganzen Region zur Folge haben.
Amherd und ihre Delegation
schauen sich vor Ort
solche Munitionskammern an.
Wie soll all die Munition
geborgen und vernichtet werden?
Eine komplexe und gefährliche
Aufgabe - und sehr teuer dazu.
Man rechnet mit bis zu 1 Mrd. Fr.
Die Menschen in Mitholz warten mit
Bangen auf Entscheidungen des VBS.
Ich arbeite an diesem Dossier,
und es liegt mir auf dem Magen.
Uns auch.
Ich wohne nicht hier, aber ich fahre
natürlich oft vorbei.
Ich kenne das auch.
Ich habe es mir wohl
auch einfacher vorgestellt.
Als ich das Departement übernahm und
mich in die Dossiers einarbeitete,
rief ich die Verantwortlichen zu mir
und sagte:
"Dass wir erst Mitte 2020
mögliche Varianten haben,
ist für mich unverständlich."
Ich begreife es, wenn das
der Bevölkerung zu spät ist.
Das geht mir genauso.
Ich fragte,
ob es keine Sofortmassnahmen gebe.
Ich musste mich belehren lassen,
dass das eben nicht so leicht ist.
Ich bin keine Munitionsspezialistin
oder Ingenieurin.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass ich
Vertrauen in unsere Leute habe.
Merci.
Was macht man als Bundesrätin noch,
wenn die Experten sagen,
wo es langgeht?
Die Experten
zeigen mögliche Lösungen auf -
sie zeigen,
was technisch machbar ist.
Wir müssen das dann
in politische Entscheide umsetzen.
Es nützt nichts,
wenn wir einen Expertenbericht haben
und dann nichts damit passiert.
Es ist die Aufgabe der Politik,
zu entscheiden,
welchen Vorschlag
wir annehmen wollen.
Dann sorgen wir für die Finanzierung
und die politische Umsetzung.
Acht Monate später
fällt die Entscheidung,
doch sie ist nicht erfreulich.
Ein ganzes Dorf muss weg.
Mitholz im Berner Oberland
wird geräumt,
damit der Bund
ein Munitionslager abtragen kann.
Das wurde
den rund 170 Dorfbewohnern gestern
von Bundesrätin Viola Amherd
persönlich erklärt.
Für die Bewohner
ist es ein harter Schritt.
Das ist für einen alten Menschen
nicht mehr so gut.
Man soll einen alten Baum
nicht mehr entwurzeln.
Da kamen mir die Tränen.
Das ist schon hart.
Ich dachte, ich würde in diesem Dorf
alt werden - oder weiterhin alt.
Das war wohl nichts.
Selbstverständlich ist es schöner,
wenn man positive Botschaften
überbringen kann,
aber für die Bevölkerung ist es
wichtig, zu wissen, woran sie ist.
Darum müssen wir
offen und transparent informieren
und die Sache nicht beschönigen.
Das würde keinem etwas bringen.
Ich hatte hier das Gefühl,
Sie seien sehr offen und sachlich,
aber mit den Emotionen zurückhaltend.
Ist das so?
Das kann schon ...
Ich weiss nicht, wie ...
Wenn ich Sie mit Bundesrat Ogi
oder Churchill vergleiche,
der Blut, Schweiss
und Tränen beschwor ...
Ich überlege mir nicht,
ob Sätze von mir
in die Geschichte eingehen.
Ich versuche einfach, die Menschen
auf einer Ebene anzusprechen,
die sie verstehen.
Gerade in Mitholz wurde verstanden,
was ich sagte.
Ich habe viel Empathie
mit diesen Leuten.
Ich sah als Gemeindepräsidentin
auch, wie solche Situationen sind.
Darum geht's mir nicht darum,
mich gross in Szene zu setzen
oder weiss Gott was
für eine Ansprache zu halten,
die immer wieder zitiert wird.
Mir geht es darum, mit ihnen
normal und einfach zu sprechen
und die Wahrheit zu sagen -
korrekt und normal.
Ein Riesentamtam ist mir sowieso
nicht gegeben. Das mag ich nicht.
Am 27. September 2020 ist dann der
Tag der Wahrheit für den Kampfjet -
Abstimmungstag.
Gerne hätte ich Viola Amherd
mit der Kamera begleitet,
aber sie wollte nicht.
Vielleicht hatte sie eine Vorahnung.
Wir sind
zurück im Abstimmungsstudio,
liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer.
Es ist ein ultraspannender
Abstimmungssonntag.
Bei den Kampfjets
hatten wir vorhin eine Hochrechnung,
die schlicht 50/50 lautete.
Und es bleibt bei 50/50.
Es ist noch immer alles offen.
Es gibt bei den Gegnerinnen und
Gegnern viele fröhliche Gesichter.
Nach den Umfragen im Vorfeld,
die eher schlecht aussahen,
ist das für uns
eine positive Überraschung.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich
heute Nachmittag lange hier sein
und das knappe Resultat
abwarten darf.
Es ist ein klassischer
Stadt-Land-Graben,
wie es leider bei Armeefragen
oft der Fall ist.
Aber ich hoffe weiterhin,
dass die Bevölkerung klar sieht,
dass wir die Neutralität und Souve-
ränität unseres Landes aufgeben,
wenn wir das ablehnen.
Wir wissen jetzt auch,
wie es bei den Kampfjets ausgeht.
Inzwischen ist nämlich
auch der letzte Kanton ausgezählt.
In der Schweiz
ergibt sich damit ein Ja von 50,1 %.
D.h., die Kampfjetvorlage
wurde ultraknapp angenommen.
Im Medienzentrum: Gratulationen -
zumindest von
den bürgerlichen Ratskollegen.
Da fällt einem ein Stein vom Herzen.
- Ja.
Warum wurde es so knapp?
Ich glaube,
dass es nur angenommen wurde,
weil Viola Amherd einen guten
Abstimmungskampf geführt hat.
Aber die Armee leidet unter
einem Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem.
Ich glaube, die Armee
muss über die Bücher gehen,
auch wenn sie knapp gewonnen hat.
Sie hat das nur
Viola Amherd zu verdanken.
Ich glaube, es ist Zeit,
einige Dinge in der Verteidigungs-
politik zu hinterfragen.
Warum es so knapp war?
Wir haben inzwischen
die Nachbefragungen studiert.
Da sieht man,
dass die Situation mit der Pandemie,
mit den Ängsten
und den wirtschaftlichen Einbussen
eine grosse Rolle gespielt hat.
Die Menschen haben Angst.
Sie haben wirtschaftliche Probleme
und waren darum zurückhaltend.
Das Ja hing aber auch stark
mit Ihnen zusammen.
Das haben auch die Gegner gesagt,
und Umfragen zeigen es auch.
Die Sympathiewerte waren hoch.
Am Ende war entscheidend,
dass man mehr Ihnen
als den Kampfjets zugestimmt hat.
Wie gehen Sie damit um,
dass die Mehrheit dagegen
gewesen wäre, aber Ihretwegen ...
Wenn es ein Ja zu mir war,
hätte ich lieber
ein paar Prozentpunkte mehr gehabt.
Jetzt gehen wir aber
ein Glacé kaufen.
Im Löwen?
- Ja.
Ein Glacé?
- Das musst du aber nicht filmen.
Was Viola Amherd mir zu zeigen
bereit war, hat sie gezeigt:
einen Hauch Privates
und einen Einblick in den Politalltag
der ersten Verteidigungsministerin
der Schweiz.
Nicht weniger, aber auch nicht mehr.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2021